Carnegie Mellon has a very distinguished
history and brain research starting in
the late 1950s we had some of the most
prominent people in the world that were
starting the field of computer science
and thinking about what we think of now
as artificial intelligence and so this
really set the stage that became all the
things we think of as modern brain
research through the rest of the century
and present day the human brain is a
fascinating device because it's probably
the most complex device in the known
universe and it's something that we
really don't understand very well at
this point but we have all of the
potential and all the research that
we're doing to connect all the dots my
own personal research has to do with
understanding the human visual system
and I've been interested not in how the
eye works or how the early parts of the
visual system work really how you take
all that information that's screaming
and constantly from your everyday
experience and turn that into your
experience about object scenes people
faces all the things that we actually
think about and then we interact with
all the time that really make up or
visual world it's really something that
provides incredible challenges because
incredible benefit not only for
understand the basic science but also
thinking about how we can take our
understanding of human behavior and turn
it into benefits for all society
Carnegie Mellon is very serious about
pursuing cutting-edge brain research and
cutting-edge science in general and in
particular taking the really special
things about Carnegie Mellon
particularly our engineering and our
computer science and bringing them into
how we study one of the most complex
things there's no one universal human
brain and this is something that our new
president super Suresh was really
supportive of and felt that it would be
important initiative for really the
coming decades for Carnegie Mellon brain
hub is about bringing people together in
particular bringing people together
don't traditionally talk with one
another so taking all of our engineers
all of our computer scientists all of
our brain research is oliver machine
learning experts and putting them all
together so that we can talk about
problems and figure out new ways to
solve that haven't been done before it
and we hope not only for it to be
bringing people together at Carnegie
Mellon but people together throughout
the rest of the world
you